We're gonna see if we can cook a steak with salt
And I don't mean we're gonna cook a steak that has salt on it
I mean we're gonna see if we can use a molten salt as the heat source
To cook a steak fans of the YouTube channel backyard scientist may remember a time when he tried to cook a steak using molten
Aluminum and it sort of worked
But you couldn't really eat the steak because it had a lot of molten aluminum stuck to the meat
Well hopefully if our salt does stick to the meat it will still be edible because it's salt
So we're gonna give this a try. We're gonna take some of our salt
We're gonna melt it down to a liquid in our crucible, and then we're gonna pour that onto our steak
We might try pouring it onto one side and we might try pouring the salt into the pan
And then putting the steak on top of some of that salt for the other side
We'll see
It's just kind of gonna be a little bit of an adventure
So let's fire out the furnace melt some salt and see if we can cook our dinner
This Coarser Salt is really good for putting on a steak when you're cooking in a normal method
But of course this is gonna melt down into a liquid. I don't know if it's gonna make much difference
to find out
Our salt has melted down to a liquid and our stake is in the pan ready to go
I've put this jacket on because there is moisture on the surface of the steak
And there's a chance that it could cause the molten-salt to splatter up into the air
And I don't want to get that on me
There's not so much moisture that I think there's any risk of a large steam explosion
But I do want to protect myself a little bit, so I've got the glasses and the long sleeves and of course the gloves
That is hot all right, I'm gonna try and start pouring on one end and move down to the other end
We'll see how this goes
Oh that smells so good
My goodness
Wow that is a fantastic looking crust on there
So our salt as you can see has definitely solidified
It did that pretty much as soon as it hit the pan, and we probably could have avoided that by heating up the pan
But I feel like that would be cheating then we'd be cooking your steak with a hot pan instead of with molten salt
However even though it has solidified. It is still holding a lot of heat
This kind of salt melts it just below 1500 degrees Fahrenheit
Which means that even though it's cooled down to the temperature where it's solid again
It's still very hot so it's cooking our steak pretty well
At least on the outside. We'll have to see how it's doing on the inside
All right, here's our steak
cooked on salt cooked on molten salt
We've first poured molten salt on top of it mostly it just ran off the sides it landed in the pan
And then we cook the steak on the mold and salt in the pan the outside has got a pretty good sear on it
We've got some good dryness
We've got some the Maillard effect has started giving us some nice crispy outside places
But I do suspect that the inside of the steak is going to be pretty much raw
Let's cut it open and find out how if I'm right?
Oh Yeah, so we can see that it did get cooked for about an eighth of an inch  of the way through and then the inside
Is still - oh boy, I think even calling this blue rare would be generous. It's let's see
It's cool. It's not even a little bit warm so
If you like your steak ultra blue rare, I mean this thing this thing is still mooing
I'm pretty sure I think a good vet could bring this back. It wouldn't be too late
I personally am NOT a big fan of
Super rare steaks, and I know all you stake in Thuvia South they are gonna. Be mad at me for that
I'm more of a medium. Maybe medium rare kind of guy, but this is a little too much for me
Ultra blue rare. I will still take a small bite of it
It's the texture really that I can't handle just slimy at this point, but I'll cut a piece off
mostly I just want to see if it got some good salt flavor by being cooked on salt
I didn't salt the state except for cooking it on the salt
so if I can taste any salt at all we know where it came from a
Little there's a little bit of salt flavor to it not a lot
There's a good steak
Cooked properly that would be fantastic
Turns out pouring molten hot
minerals
Salt is a mineral which means that what we made is sort of like lava
Kind of so yeah pouring molten hot minerals on top of a steak is not the ideal way to cook it
But I do have another thing that I want to try but first let's learn about our sponsor
If you like to cook at home. Hello, fresh is a great way to do it. They've really set up a system
That's convenient to use if you have a busy schedule you can choose the delivery day that works best for you
If you're going to be out of town you can pause your account for weeks at a time
All of the ingredients come pre measured in handy labelled meal kits so you know which ingredients go with which recipe
Unlike at a grocery store and of course the whole kit is delivered right to your door in
Recyclable insulated packaging hellofresh offers a wide variety of chef curated recipes that are different every week
they have the classic veggie and family plans to choose from the recipes are designed to only take about 30 minutes to prep so you're
Not gonna have to spend all night in the kitchen cooking several of the meals are designed to be one pot recipes
For speedy cooking and minimal cleanup each week one meal in the classic menu is designed to only take 20 minutes to prep
I thought the instructions were easy to follow prep time was quick and the quality of the food was excellent
It's a really convenient and easy service to use knowing that you're getting full meals in just the right portion sizes
For $30 off your first week of hellofresh visit hellofresh.com and enter promo code king of random 30
now let's get back to the steak before we started melting the salt for this steak
We actually took a second steak and put it in what's called a sous-vide cooker
That's a device that keeps a bath of water at an extremely precise temperature so right now
I've got some steak cooking in a bath of water at about
134 degrees Fahrenheit, which is a good temperature to get a nice medium-rare cook all the way through it's in a plastic bag
Which keeps it from being in contact with the water directly
But it still gets all of the heat and since the water
Is being held at a very precise temperature the steak will cook all the way through at exactly that temperature without overcooking anywhere
So now let's take our sous-vide cooked
Stake out and let's put that into the pan and try the same thing with that and see if we can use salt
Instead of for cooking the steak all the way through just to finish up the outside of it
Alright there we go our steak is now cooked all the way through at just the perfect temperature however
Being heated by water doesn't really give us a nice outside look to our steak
And that's why we want to cook the outside with our molten salt
That is some very hot salt
That's pretty good, that is a delicious looking ribeye right there
All right see how this looks on the inside
Still got a little bit of pink. I'll admit that even though I don't like it rare
This is probably a little overcooked for me a little bit more pink on the inside
Is more of what I look for but that still looks pretty delicious
Now this again see if it's got any salt flavor to it the last one didn't have much
See if this is any different
Not a lot
This is a very good steak
Like I said, I really enjoy it when the texture has changed
This is why I don't prefer my steaks rare this the texture has definitely changed
And it did get cooked a little bit more than I wanted so I probably had my sous-vide machine
Set a few degrees too high even though
I cooked this with salt none of it really stuck to the steak
So I'm going to add a little bit more salt, and this is gonna be my dinner
Cooking a steak using molten salt. It does get a pretty nice sear on the outside
Especially if you take care to flip the steak down in the salt as is cooling in the pan
It doesn't really do a whole lot of searing as you pour it on it. Just sort of skitters across
I think we have the Leighton prospect making the salt not really stick to or touch the steak very much
Overall if we pre cook the inside of the steak
And then use the salt as a sear on the outside it does work although
It's a bit of a roundabout way of doing it
It would be easier to just sear it in a pan or on a grill or something like that
Or maybe just sear it directly in the foundry
If you've got some cool ideas of other things you want to see us try using molten salt, let us know down in the comments below
If we use your idea will send you 25 bucks
Thanks again to our sponsor for this video, HelloFresh. Check the link in the description below for a discount off of your first order